you know the negative voice in my head
would say all the things that i did
wrong and then it would start to be even
louder like see i told you you shouldn't
have gone for it see i told you you were
going to fail right and so it it it is a
thing that can be crippling and can
prevent you from moving forward pulling
to your knees doesn't mean you have to
wait to be saved you can get back up
because you are your own hero i say
that's my goal and now i better bust my
ass and figure out how on earth i get
there yeah i actually do want to be the
number one salesperson but i freaking
hate sending emails and so i only sent
30. so now the most amazing thing about
this process is it allows you to say do
i actually want to be in sales
because maybe my mission is still right
but now i don't know if the path i've
chosen is right and that's the beauty of
setting goals well actually that's a lie
i was about to lie to you evan so the
truth is
believe nation i am super excited to
have back on the channel author of the
new york times best-selling book radical
confidence lisa bill you how you doing
what up evan i love the the pun out in
the universe telling what you know where
we're gonna get to i love it so full
disclosure for people watching lisa and
i recording this before the book dropped
i still have the galley version that the
non-pink side version so this is extra
rare but i say that because i think a
lot of people
have goals like that i want to be a new
york times bestselling author
and then they they don't tell their
friends or they don't tell their their
husband or wife and and they don't would
not say it on a podcast or interview and
maybe they have it on their vision board
but most days they don't actually
believe it
so so when i say i love the reaction
it's like hey we're putting the pin out
there in the universe to make this
happen a lot of people you're so crisp
in the book on setting goals and
eyeballing them like a shirtless ryan
gosling
i love that you put that line
i mean that's not how i eyeball my goals
but i get it you know
i get where you're going with it
for people who who have goals like that
and they have they have like days where
they feel like it's possible but then
most days they feel like it's not what's
the advice that you give them yeah evan
i love this so much because here's the
thing once upon a time i used to be the
person you can't say that out loud and
there was multiple reasons one i was so
afraid that if i didn't get there i
would be so embarrassed and i'd be like
i'd have to tell everyone that i failed
and then the fear of failing was so
crippling that it then stopped me from
saying it out loud
now to your point if you don't say it
out loud then um at least the people
around you like i think friendships and
relationships can help you stay
accountable for the goals in the life
that you want and not to say them out
loud is actually giving missing an
opportunity to help you actually get to
that goal that you want so that is so
important and then also a big thing is i
realized that it's not just a fleeting
idea or a fleeting like oh i want to be
a new york times bestseller it's
i say that's my goal and now i better
bust my ass and figure out how on earth
i get there so nothing's by chance it
doesn't mean that i feel good like oh
i'm confident i'm going to get there no
no evan i'm petrified i don't know if
i'm gonna get there i don't even know if
i'm gonna sell one book in fact i
probably will because my mum bought it
but you know i mean like i don't have
cockiness and thinking oh if i just say
it's gonna happen then i'm gonna get
there i take ownership and
responsibility
even though i'm petrified to say it out
loud that that's what i want and that's
what radical confidence is going in with
saying this is what i want i don't know
if i'm gonna succeed i may fall on my
face and i'm scared but you know what
i'm going to take a bunch of tools that
i've created and i will keep moving
forward and that's what radical
confidence is it's not like just saying
oh you know feel the fear and do it
anyway it's about fear
feeling the fear and having a freaking
game plan and a step-by-step
instructional manual on how on earth
you're going to get to that end goal so
anyway talking about the new york times
you know the first people i called was
jay shetty mel robbins brendan bashard
right i'm calling on them like guys what
tell me all the things i don't know and
i had a list of questions and i went in
very purposefully with the what are the
things i'm not thinking of what's the
best thing what's the worst thing what
are the pitfalls what are the most
amazing magical
moments that you didn't realize and i
got prepared and that's the key have a
plan get prepared and then every day
march towards that whether you feel
great about it or not i love that you
use it as accountability it was like a
magic word that stood out as you were as
you were explaining it that the goal
becomes your accountability to show up
for today
one of the things that i love about you
is that
i understand that the goal is not the
whole thing right i mean ultimately you
want to have impact you could have you
could have done you didn't you don't do
any of this stuff you don't build impact
theory you made enough money from quest
you could have had the life that you
want but money is not
enough it's not the actual life that you
want it's much more about the impact
than than any individual goal so what
ends up happening then when you don't
i think that's the biggest downsides
like if you don't hit your goal when you
said oh my gosh i used to be so
embarrassed ever wouldn't hit my goal i
think most people are still stuck there
like they're so afraid to share their
goals because if they don't hit it
they're going to be really embarrassed
so if you can
remove some of the pain around not
hitting the goal
then maybe people be a lot more willing
to share it and start taking action so
what happens if you don't hit one of
your big goals
yeah it used to literally um crush me
and it was you know the negative voice
in my head would say all the things that
i did wrong and then it would start to
be even louder like see i told you you
shouldn't have gone for it see i told
you you were gonna fail right and so it
it it is a
thing that can be crippling and can
prevent you from moving forward so
there's a couple of things there first
of all is everything is aligned with my
mission
i have a mission and that is my freaking
north star my goals are just in service
of my mission so my mission if i just i
think it's very important i want your
audience to actually hear like for me it
was very important for me to be very
succinct on what that mission is
so that there's no room to go well yeah
sure i'll do this and sure i'll do that
you know how many things um like do we
love to do or want to do but is it
aligned with that north star of yours so
getting very succinct on what your
mission in is mission is is extremely
important and that's actually step
number one so for me is to um create
empowering content
for 14 year old girls to believe in
themselves so they don't have to un
spend the next 20 years unwiring the
negative mindset that i had to do right
very succinct i know the who 14 year old
girls i know the why so they don't have
to un spend the next 20 years unwiring
and i know the what creating content so
i have a very clear mission
and i know what levers to pull so i know
content is going to be the massive level
that i'm going to be pulling so now i go
how do i set goals to create content
that is aligned with my mission
and so what i do is i'll create that
goal i'll create the path to that goal
okay step one it has to be binary evan
you can't convince us you can't give
yourself wiggle room to get out of it so
for instance
if my mission is perfect example
actually using the book if your mission
is to help people on their health
journey and you say all right how am i
going to do that i want to work for
quest in sales because i know when i
sell people quest bars i'm actually
helping them on their journey all right
you know your mission and help people in
the health space you know that what role
you want to play you want to sell bars
in order to create that and now let's
say your goal is to become um the best
sales person of the year
because now that aligns with your
mission right because that is now it to
you a way of showing that you are
actually executing on your mission so
now that's the goal i want to be the top
sales person of the year great how do
you do that break that down into smaller
goals all right so if i know i want to
be the great person of the year i need
to win month over month amazing how do
you win month
over month that means i need to make 20
sales
great how many emails do you have to
send out in order to make those 20 sales
i have to send out
70 emails every single day because my
conversion shows that's what's going to
get me to those sales amazing now you
know you have to send out 70 emails
every single day and you have a road map
because even when you don't feel it even
when you're not sure even when you're
fearful they're not going to hit your
goal you need to keep on that path and
when you have this road map that says
did you send out 70 emails yes or no
make it binary
and then assess every month or quarterly
whatever you want but i like to assess
every month now what i do is i look back
and say did i send those 70 emails and
if my answer is no
why not
because sometimes we have a mission
but our day-to-day lives we actually
don't want to do what it takes
and i think that it's beautiful to just
own it and say you know what yeah i
actually do want to be the number one
salesperson but i freaking hate sending
emails and so i only sent 30. so now the
most amazing thing about this process is
it allows you to say do i actually want
to be in sales
because maybe my mission is still right
but now i don't know if the path i've
chosen is right and that's the beauty of
setting goals it doesn't have to be did
i succeed or not it is did i hit it if
not why does this align with who i am
and what i want to achieve
yes or no and so it to me allowed me to
every time i felt badly about myself
every time i worried about failing every
time i wasn't sure if this actually is
what i should be doing because i'm
inadequate at this skill set
i could talk myself out of it but i know
talking myself out of it actually won't
be in service of my mission
so that's to me how you set small goals
reassess and no don't judge yourself if
you hit that goal just ask yourself why
not
how much do you celebrate when you hit
the goal
hmm
i've learned to celebrate the lesson
because if i hit well actually that's a
lie i was about to lie to you evan so
the truth is when you hit a goal yes
give yourself that pat on the back
because for so long i was seeking
external validation to make me feel good
and so what happens is you're waiting
for other people to give you the pad on
the back and now you're not actually
encouraging yourself and so to me you
have to be your biggest cheerleader so
when you hit a goal absolutely freaking
celebrate say you know what i was the
person that showed up today in order to
do that i was the person that sent those
70 emails no one else did it
i did that and giving yourself a pat on
the back makes is so freaking important
because it allows you then to do the
next thing it allows you to do the next
thing because if you all you're looking
at is that big audacious year five years
ten years goal you know we're trying to
build disney now imagine evan i never
celebrated any goals because i keep
saying well we haven't bought disney yet
now it's just like i'm not allowing
myself the small wind
so that's important but at the same time
i actually also try not to focus on the
fact that i hit my goal because when
talking about moments of failure moments
where you don't reach it how on earth do
you keep going that's the question
i ask myself and so i look at fail and i
look at things like that if i didn't hit
my goal and i said well did i try did i
give it my all and if not actually good
i'm glad that i noticed that i didn't
give it my all and now i'm going to kick
myself up my own butt and tell myself
hey next time if you want to reach that
goal you're going to have to keep going
hard or you're going to you know have to
send those emails
um
but
what if you did do everything what if
you sent those 70 emails what if you got
up every single morning and was so
aligned and you still didn't reach your
goal
i think it's imperative in those moments
to say i did everything i set out to do
and i didn't nail it okay i'm so proud
of myself that i still did everything i
said to do
now how do i pivot or tweak or change
what i need to do for my next set of
goals in order to get there
and so i think the the imperative part
of this is is being proud of yourself
for being the person that always shows
up being proud of yourself that you're
the person that can get up after failure
and being proud of yourself that you're
the learner and when i was able to keep
repeating these things to me it really
did help me to move forward in spite of
failure in spite of facing my
inadequacies and seeing how bad i was at
certain things and allowing myself to
keep going so that i could get better
each day
one of the things i struggle a lot with
and maybe get some lisa bill you
coaching live here
it's all mission right like i think the
world's biggest problems people don't
believe in themselves i think everybody
has i call it michael jordan level
genius that's something and i want to
help be a conduit to help people unlock
it and chase that down like imagine a
world where everybody's living their
michael jordan level genius i love that
but on the goals i really struggle uh
because what i've found i barely
celebrate hitting an outcome even this
as an example so like 20 minutes before
this i'm i'm just taking some notes uh
lisa coming on i'm pacing in the in the
in the kitchen nina's like are you
nervous
it's like yeah but it'll be fun because
lisa is always great
and that's more the celebrations like
hey doing doing something that you know
i wanted i wanted to be a good
reflection for the book a good
reflection for you
and how well
something does
just
it's becoming less and less important to
me when i hit a million subscribers we
did a live stream and that was more for
the audience and for me to celebrate
them and then when i hit two or three
it'd just be okay like the celebration
is more the day to day and i honestly
really struggle getting excited enough
for any goal
and yet still wake up every day trying
to pursue the mission so what what would
you
what is how does that land what should i
be doing differently where am i screwing
up lisa
so i wouldn't say screwing up heaven but
i would say evolving
um
and so i think the key is
how are you identifying when you're on
your mission like how do you know so yes
let's say for instance you've got two
million you know subscribers um that's
that's a number right and so how are you
associating that number with put what's
pulling at your heart strings it's
always a an individual human
so it's it's talking to you today it's a
comment that comes in the channel it's a
video dm from someone on instagram it's
all the stuff that we love receiving of
hey lisa your video changed my life or
you gave me the confidence but nobody
else would like it's all the it's all
qualitative versus
you know if we have 500 million views on
the channel i don't even know what that
means like that's bigger than the u.s
population right
i can't it doesn't emotionally get me
hyped up i don't care enough about like
10 million subscribers or 5 million or
whatever the next thing is it's not that
alone is not enough to get me like i got
to get up today and do it but i've
gotten every day up and made videos for
13 years except
that one moment when you know my dog
passed away and i couldn't do it um so
i've always struggled i probably have a
quarterly crisis of confidence to say
but what are my next goals what's my
next what's my next goal be and i never
get excited enough about a specific
number or metric so it just goes back
okay just keep doing the work yeah okay
this is so amazing i love this
discussion because here's the thing
you have to cultivate it this stuff
doesn't happen by accident
and so for instance with the numbers i
totally hear you like it's like it does
rather abstract and i get moved by
letters emails messages that's what
rocks my world that's what my like when
i get i'm getting the chills just
thinking about it when i get especially
like a guy when he says lisa i've just
bought your book for my daughter because
she needs it
that pulls up my heartstrings at quest
when i was knee-deep in running up
our shipping department i had zero idea
what i was doing i spent eight years as
a stay-at-home wife so here i was i had
40 employees underneath me in the
shipping department i had zero idea what
i was doing and every time i was scared
nervous afraid had no idea what i was
doing i was like how do i make sure that
when i'm tired
how on earth do i keep showing up with
enthusiasm and love my life and i
started to realize there were moments
where certain letters so with the one
letter that came to me that really stuck
with me was from a woman who had um
suffered from an anorexia she had
something like she was 40 pounds or
something so she was in hospital on her
deathbed
and she'd really struggled and she wrote
a letter saying thank you for for
creating quest bars it has now made me
okay with calories again
and you've now developed a community
that i feel safe that i can talk about
my health issues
evan that letter came in
in 2000 and
i don't know 12.
i still remember it
there was one more letter i remember
a mother wrote in saying my son has type
1 diabetes is hyper and diabetic
and every time he's like five years old
and every time he goes to parties in
schools i am like the terrible mom that
has to take all the candy away that has
to make sure he doesn't eat all the cake
like all the other kids
and she was like and he he's tried quest
and it doesn't spike his insulin
and now we're like baking with it we're
making all these foods with it and
thanks to you i feel like a better
mother
that again was 10 years ago
i hold on to those letters i've
cultivated the meaning behind that i use
that as my why
and so going back to what you're saying
about the numbers i very purposely will
put in things that say okay evan
um when you hit three million right you
have to decide this beforehand
when you hit three million you are going
to have
your team pull their most favorite
comments of the year
and what you're going to do is you're
going to take three hours and you're
going to have lunch with your team
and you're all going to read out the the
letters or the comments
that impacted you guys the most in that
year
and then maybe you reach out to your fan
base and you say guys we're going to do
a celebration and we want to hear from
you i want to do a couple of little
videos so have your fans submit little
videos to you and really create
cultivate an occasion that allows you to
emotionally
um indulge in what you're actually
creating and the impact you're having
that won't happen by accident and when
you've got such a business mindset like
you have you're so focused on momentum
on moving forward that that's just part
of your personality don't be yourself up
over it it's amazing it's beautiful it's
allowed you to still show up after
freaking 13 years and so now love that
part of you be proud of that part of you
but just implement other little
strategies in your you know your um your
process
that allow you to take those moments and
maybe you're not the right person to do
that evan maybe you are the business
mind that actually doesn't think like
that and now you have to um actually
choose someone on your team that is so
for instance me and my husband we have
been together for 22 years we're about
to celebrate our 20-year wedding
anniversary and thank you
and um
we literally said to each other after a
while where it's like i would feel
disconnected from him right now turn
around to him and i'm like
babe like aren't you feeling it and he's
like no and i'm like well do you not
care about me as much as i care about
you where and i would used to take that
offensive but over time what we realize
is i have a much more sensitive monitor
of when we're starting to drift apart so
what we did is we said okay no shame
it's not a bad thing about you babe and
i realize that you just have a different
barometer than i do so why don't we set
me lisa billy as the responsible party
of this relationship to be the person
that weighs the flag when we start to
split apart and we start to not have
that connection we agreed on it amazing
now he does his thing and i'm the
responsible party
now going back to your question evan if
maybe this isn't your skill set and
that's okay so now choose someone in
your team where they love this that they
have this barometer that they understand
and get
oh okay it's coming up to the year mark
i'm the responsible party or not even
the year mark the three million mark
whatever you want to make i'm the
responsible party because this isn't
skill set and that's okay we need to
stop judging ourselves for things we're
not good at and just say that's the
person that's now going to be doing it
and they're going to provide an event
they're the one who's going to pull the
comments and you see how like that can
then
spread out into a strategy
that allows you to lean into it more and
more
i like it i mean as you were given that
advice my my first thought went to well
why wait till we hit 4 million
subscribers let's let's do it right now
i love it and that's amazing the only
problem is how i think of things as
being sustainable what are the processes
that i'm going to put in for the next 20
years to keep me going so i actually
love the like let's just freaking do now
amazing
but are you just going to wait for you
to be spontaneous evan it's been 15
years right first time you're being
spontaneous right so just think about
the realities of how you actually
function and that's the thing is like
just be honest and so i the whole book
is always that like each chapter i take
you through hey this is how you deal
with it be honest with yourself give
yourself grace but you have to be honest
with who you are as a person right now
and then just say evan is this the
skills that you actually want to
cultivate like does it actually bother
you that you're not the person that
celebrates and if it does okay great if
it actually doesn't
then have that skill set for someone
else and bring that person in
yeah i think that becomes the ultimate
question of self-awareness right it's
like it doesn't bother me but so that
means it's either nothing
or it's the whole thing and i'm just not
seeing it and it's just this big blind
spot because i've said that it doesn't
bother me right maybe it should because
it's if if that is the secret then it
unlocks an entire new level entire new
world
um so i don't know it's just a constant
you know maybe once a quarter maybe just
i'll have to call you once a quarter and
we could talk to it
there it is and then also i'll just say
one thing that you just said is so you
said the word should i think that that's
actually really detrimental to us as
well right like maybe i should be
celebrating even just that is almost
forcing something upon you you do so
much beautiful work that you put out
into the world like you so much
beautiful work that you do that it's
like if there's something that you have
a missing piece to we need to examine
that right and that does become the
self-awareness piece but if you don't
have that missing piece but you're
saying it because you feel like you
should i just think we need to knock the
[ __ ] out of your brain right because you
create so much beautiful impact to
people and so it needs to go back to how
do you feel do you feel like there's
something missing not what everyone else
does or how everyone else acts it's how
do you keep showing up and what is that
head do you need to overcome i love the
language reframe and guys in radical
confidence everything is i can
i can i can i can right like every every
page almost starts with i can and a new
kind of empowering belief that you
should go and and should you can
[Laughter]
you can go and chase down if you want to
i usually love asking people who their
heroes are because i think that kind of
brings a lot of insight into who they
look up to and tells a deeper story and
i would have guessed maybe someone like
wonder woman even though that's a
fictional character but on the cover of
your book for you you write the 10 no
sbs 10 no bs lessons on becoming the
hero
of your own life so yeah
so who which is i love it who who is
hero lisa
to lisa right now oh
so my hero self is the the person that
helps me get back up
and i
i have told myself that that enough
again i go to everything i cultivate the
way that i think it doesn't happen by
accident and it's difficult right so it
becomes a what are the thing i'm going
to work on now how do i create the habit
and so it really is repetition creates
habit repetition creates habit so i tell
myself i'm the hero of my own life so i
actually eventually do step up and
become the hero of my own life
and so when i think about what that
means the thing that's helped me
continue to move forward is not judge
myself on falling not judge myself on
failing but
being proud that i'm my own hero that
puts on my cape and gets back up when i
do and even that framing now allows me
to take pride in being the person that
gets back up from failure so i'm
cultivating the feelings that i don't
let the fear of failure stop me from
moving forward and so that's kind of
like my hero
side of me but that all came to the fact
when
my husband i was really really sick one
day and i've had massive guide issues
for years and years and years i was in
the middle of a photo shoot and i had
the worst stomach pains i've ever had
and i ran upstairs i hid from the photo
shoe and i was like i'll just be back in
a second and i fell to the floor like to
the floor on my knees could barely
breathe was like i don't you know this
is excruciating i need my husband to
come save me and that was the thing
because i met tom when i was young so he
was my partner in crime and so he it was
like he was my superhero he was my you
know my he-man and i you know i love
saying that and so i was like okay i
need him to come save me and so we have
a rule in the billion household
you can call i can ignore you you can
call me twice i can ignore you again but
if you call me three times by hell or
high water i don't care who you're with
you can be with the president you can be
with obama like it doesn't matter you
can be with oprah like you better say
sorry i gotta go i gotta answer this
phone because that means emergency
status i'm on the floor i'm taking this
deep breath i'm calling my husband so
i'm like all right he's ignoring me but
i got him on call three on call three
evan he doesn't answer
and so in that moment
i was like how the hell do i get off the
floor i need him i need him and i kept
repeating i need him and in that moment
it was that where it's like okay well
what are you gonna do he's not around
you're gonna stay on the floor or and
that's when i realized
i don't need him i want him
but you know what lisa you're your own
hero get up off the damn floor and in
that moment was the time that i realized
metaphorically and physically and really
that falling to your knees doesn't mean
you have to wait to be saved you can get
back up because you are your own hero
i love it shout out to chapter five in
the book which is
uh
life is not a fairy tale save yourself
wow evan i'm so freaking impressed
hell's yet let's go so how do you know
and i guess another self-awareness
question but how do you know when
you need a hug and tell yourself that
you did the best you could with
everything that you had at this moment
and how do you know when you should give
yourself a push to say
you're not doing enough and you're not
going to hit your goal like how do you i
think most people get it wrong and we're
just way too hard on ourselves and then
stuck in zero momentum land so how do
you know when
i mean i would assume that for you
you're mostly in push mode and every now
and then you need the hug you know i
think that's what achievers do right um
but how do you differentiate when you
need a hug and when you need the push to
say no no stop crying get up you're fine
you got to go save this yourself yeah i
love that question everything has become
in hindsight so i've had to mess up many
many times and then learn my lesson
along the way i wish i had a better
answer for people at home i actually
don't i just realized that
pushing myself at quest where i didn't
give myself grace at all like i'm an
all-in type person so assess who you are
as a human like your fundamental
characteristics as a person i go all in
i am like
ocd obsessive compulsive be as perfect
as you possibly can now look i'm not
saying that serves me that's just my
natural personality
so i was like back before i had a growth
mindset keep going keep going push
yourself your your weekly so if you let
this crush you you know like
um you said that you were gonna do it
and you have to do it even if you're
about to break your health like that was
the mentality i had
and if i hadn't had my health issues i
don't know how i would think like that
actually worries me
but it comes to the point where you know
i was just grinding with quests so much
i was never putting myself first
self-care was not a thing for me i was
like self-care for wusses you write like
that was the mentality i had
and it ended up totally burning me out
to the point where the dream came true
we got the dream house you can't believe
it and my health absolutely crushed and
it like to me in the book i it's
basically it happened in one day where i
drank champagne and my gut just fell
apart now of course it felt like
exploded now of course that was 10 15
years of not taking care of myself not
thinking about self-care not giving
myself a break
and that day evan i've never been the
same since and that was like six years
ago
and so i sadly had to go through the
downfall of what it looks like when you
don't give yourself a hug
and i am desperately
grasping at straws even to this day on
how i articulate
that so that
people don't end up there because i
don't know if i would have heard people
because my dad used to say to me you're
pushing yourself too hard people used to
say to me you're pushing yourself too
hard and in my head you know what the
voice in my head was saying
they're just not strong like you
right and like you're nodding it's like
we all know it's like when you're an
overachiever that's the language that
gets you to keep going but i
noticed where that took me
it didn't serve me i've been battling
trying to get back to normal quote on
quo for the last six years
and so when you're that sick when you
can't stand up for longer than five
minutes at a time
when you're so um
grappled with stomach pain you can i
mean literally i i ate like four things
in an entire year like the four same
things my hair was falling out my nails
were brittle when you go through that i
made a promise to myself i said lisa you
did this to yourself
all the years of very bad relationships
with food thinking fat was bad thinking
carbs were bad getting sick and taking
too many antibiotics
all of this was something you've done to
yourself but that's the most beautiful
thing because now you can take control
back and the control means making sure
you give yourself those hugs making sure
you never get back here again and what
does that actually look like so i want
people right now to start becoming
self-aware
and just take note of their lives and
say okay what does it feel like when i
get five hours sleep oh my god i feel
really bad all right mark that down
how's it for when you get six hours
sleep seven hours sleep where's that
mark huh that you know allows you to
show up and freaking crush it
not like oh my god i can get three hours
sleep and i can
you know barely get through the day but
that doesn't serve you or your goal
so now how do you function every day
show up to freaking crush it light that
fire under your ass because you know
what you're capable of and know when to
back off and say oh wow i'm actually
walking that tight rope now and if i
keep going i know myself well enough i
know myself that i'm going to crash and
burn and that doesn't serve me so in
those moments when you start to identify
oh i've had four nights in a row where
i've only had five hours sleep i know
where this is going because i've been
there before i jotted it down and i made
myself a promise that if i get to the
point where i've had four days of less
sleep than i need i'm going to give
myself a hug i'm going to give myself
the grace i'm going to make sure that i
get eight hours sleep which means i have
to go to bed at this time it all comes
down to
having a plan knowing yourself because
when you find yourself in those moments
your negative thought or your mind may
try to convince you to just keep going
when actually all you really need is a
hug and down time
what's interesting is you know when
somebody's telling you hey lisa you're
pushing yourself too hard and you say
well you're just not as strong as me as
the like internal rebuttal not the thing
that you would say out loud
the
i mean it's 85 true
you know that's why we believe it
because for the most part you are
stronger than them
right now where they're at so we believe
it's not like a total lie you're not
lying to yourself it's fact you look at
them and you are stronger than them it's
not that you're a better human or
anything but you're stronger than them
it's interesting to have i like the
rules right it's like how do you
identify that 15 of the time when it is
actually true and you should be hugging
yourself and taking a break so like four
days in a row of less sleep than usual
so i'm going to x because it kind of
gets the brain out of the way of you
convincing yourself like okay here's
here's my rule are there any other rules
that you've set for yourself whether
it's
feeling a certain way or a certain
number of hours of sleep or a certain
number of hours worked does it have you
set other rules for yourself oh i have
many many rules evan
that's how i show
up every day i have to like everything
i'm saying i really want people to
listen so like how do you show up and
have the confidence i just have the
rules and those rules allow me to get
out of my own head and look i adjust my
rules as i go if the goal if the rule
doesn't serve the goal and doesn't serve
my health and doesn't serve who i want
to be and show up every day i change the
rule
um
but to your point actually i'd actually
like to challenge that a little because
here's the thing
i am now the person that says to other
people you may be working yourself too
hard
now that doesn't mean that i couldn't
work myself harder i can i've just been
there and i know where it leads
so i actually
you're right in the sense that some
people will say oh you're working too
hard because they're it's that mirror
reflection right so it's like if i
worked like for instance tom
tom calculated something like he works
125 hours a week or something
it was insane it was insane and
literally i said to him if i worked as
hard as you i would crash and burn but
he doesn't so do i admit yeah he's way
stronger than i am i don't judge myself
for it more for him you know great um
but i would never be the one to then say
to him if he was working my amount of
hours but you shouldn't work more
because you're gonna burn no no he
wouldn't burn i would so i think that
there's a fine line between um someone
telling you hey you're about to burn out
and what their weaknesses are and their
level of burnout is and then assessing
does this actually align with your level
of burnout and maybe you know also the
person that's saying it but that's what
i'm thinking too right like if you told
me hey evan i think you're working too
hard like lisa bill you're telling me
i'm working too hard i gotta i gotta
question my life right now
[Laughter]
like because there's a lot of respect
for that thing right where i think most
of the people who are telling us you're
working too hard are people who hate
their own lives who are not chasing
their goals and their dreams and you're
already the most ambitious person in
your circle and the people around you
are telling you to take it easy and so
we don't respect them for that thing we
might respect them for many other things
so uh yeah that's fair yeah that's a
very good point
the life of the bill used gets turned
into a movie who's playing lisa and tom
who's playing oh
i don't know who was it the other person
the other day i was it's like meryl
streep can play lisa and tom she's that
good
i don't know if tom would want to be
played by meryl streep i think we should
ask him that i don't know the funny
thing is he's obsessed with her just as
much she's so good literally you can put
her in any role and she could crush it
um
i love eva longoria um i
don't know if she yeah i've actually
seen some content of hers that she i
think could really pull like off um and
then do i get to choose ryan gosling
because then i get to see him in real
life sure there you go all right
the question from in the book so this
this line i had to read a couple times
and i wanted like this is one of the oh
this is the next book page 88 at least
in the advanced copy 88 uh you see you
need to mourn the life you have
to give up in order to create the life
that you want yeah
why do we need to mourn the life that
we've got right now in order to get the
life we want so here's the thing i i
think just because you want one thing
doesn't mean you don't want other things
and i that was actually one of the
problems for me it's like oh well you
want this and you want this i want to
make movies i want to have kids i wanted
to be a great wife like so it's like all
these things that i want and then when i
sat down and said well what's the actual
life that i actually want and then
identifying does that align with all the
other things because sometimes you have
to let things go
and so for me when i realized i love
business oh my god like every day i get
challenged every day i get to push
myself and my skill sets
and then i started to realize does this
mean i don't want children and so i had
to process
because i when i married tom i told him
babe i want four kids
i want to feel what it's like to have a
baby inside me i want to feel growing
like i really do i want to see little
tom running around like it would melt my
heart and that's genuinely a massive
part of who i am even today evan like it
would melt my heart to see a little tom
running around i would love to be called
mummy
i would love to i mean you know my puppy
just passed away and he's like the
closest i've had to being called mummy
and so i love that and yet i love
crushing business
every day i like going hard i like
working 13 14 hours a day i like being
able to say i want to do this and
working towards it and seeing it coming
to fruition so i had to process what is
the life i actually want on a day to day
and i realized i really wanted to crush
business now look many women do both
many women choose i want to have a
family and
but for me when i just assess to go 15
hours a day and 16 hours a day working
i don't feel like i don't think i would
be a good mother and that's my choice i
just don't think i would be a good
mother so what i realized is i actually
don't want children anymore but there's
still a massive side of me
the feeling the baby growing the little
tom that still would want it so i
actually realized i had to grieve the
idea that i was going to be a mother
and i had to because
processing emotions are so important if
you ignore them they will catch up to
you
and i'm very very aware of that because
i've done that sadly too many times
ignore ignore ignore and if i ignored
that side of me that still wanted to be
a mother i think i would have
had um it would have been harder for me
to move forward with confidence that
being in business was the right decision
and so to me it is about how do you feel
good about the decisions you make and
not have regret
and so i went through a whole process
and i really break it down in the book
of how i went through every option well
what if i freeze my eggs and what if
this happens and what if this happens
what if i decide not to have children
and now i'm you know i actually am 42
and tom
god forbid dies like i hate to talk
about it but that's how i think evan
because i never want to regret the
decision to not have children and so i
had to go through every single scenario
of what is the worst situations and am i
okay with them
because if you don't process it i worry
it would have come up in the future
and so i knew i had to move forward with
utter clarity that i was making the
right decision and so along with that
came the idea that i had to grieve being
a mother tom had to grieve um the fact
that he was losing me as a stay-at-home
wife because that was a i had been doing
that for eight years for eight years he
didn't have to think about anything evan
i cooked i cleaned i put his clothes out
for him he literally would get up his
clothes were waiting next to the bed he
literally didn't have to even to go into
the closet it was right next to the bed
and so i'd been doing that for eight
years and so my transition was very
important that as a couple we went
through it together
and so i had to give him the space and
respect and i said to him i think you
have to grieve the wife you thought i
was going to be and the wife i am
currently because i want to pivot and i
want to be a badass entrepreneur
and because i gave him the grace to
grieve and we went through it what does
that grief look like it was you know
like a kind of joke but it's like yeah
you know weaning
weaning him off slowly of me being the
same
home wife so it was like all right i did
that for seven days all babe maybe we'll
do it for six days and then we'll go
down to five days and then we'll go down
to four and then you know by the end of
it now i cook for him on the weekends
and he deals with his own clothes and
his own breakfast lunch and dinner and
so doing that process not just being
like well forget about this is who i am
now really allowed us to make that pivot
with such confidence and such um with
without the fear of the regret of like
what if this comes up in the future
because we've thought through it we've
processed it we've spoken about it and
we've taken the time to let go of the
person we thought we were going to be i
love it i mean one of the things i love
about you the most and there's so many
things to love but is is
the combination of
just focus slash determination
in in kindness and love and i don't know
what language to use but
uh i look at i look at tom tom sent me a
text as an example he's like uh hey evan
out of the blue random i just want to
let you know how much i appreciate you
and then a second texas saying i didn't
send that to everybody that was just for
you
okay thank you tom and he had these
moments of like
warmth and kindness and love
and then moments of just on and intense
and like we are crushing this thing and
and you've got both but you seem to
meld them very easily together so it's
not like black or white and i feel like
i'm much more in the time categories
like there's love and then there's focus
and attention and we're going to crush
this thing and so i don't know if
there's any advice or even a question in
there um but i just really respect and
admire how you're so easily able to
navigate
the focus and intense and in drive
uh with the kindness and love and
compassion that's so interesting because
here's the thing it doesn't feel like
it's
smooth and natural because it's so
calculated on my part when i say
calculated i mean because i need to
cultivate these feelings because i can
get in my head so much evan i can be
like oh my god you're you're terrible
lisa you're not good at this like i can
i am not naturally the person that can
have the grace and the crushing at the
same time and so it's interesting that
it is perceived to be
fluid because inside it's not and so i
absolutely have strategies and tips
because it doesn't it's not fluid so
right now
in fact you know we kind of said this
before we started to roll um before i
came on this podcast i text tom so my
puppy my 17 and a half year old boy just
passed away
and i'm really trying to make sure like
how do i give myself grace with the
emotions but still freaking sharp and
crush the book because it's important to
me
and so i text him about an hour ago and
i was like babe i just i need i'm
struggling a little today i need some
extra hugs because that's important tell
your partner what you need no one's a
mind reader embrace it don't feel guilty
about what you need to just articulate
it so i text him that and then as we
were
i was coming on the show i start to gear
up because i realize right now the
softness in me isn't going to be able to
really empower people to freaking go out
and crush their lives so i was like okay
i need to show up for you evan so what
do i do i put on my wonder woman
necklace
i put on my watch which i read a comment
the other day which actually made me
laugh they're like that watch is wearing
lisa it's so freaking big but it kind of
feels like you know my wonder woman
cuffs you know like you're preparing for
battle right and i put my makeup on and
i'm listening literally i have my
headphones in and i've got one song on
repeat and my current song is um
business like let's get down let's get
down to business
um yesterday i always have i yeah it's
such a great song i always have my go-to
which is survivor with destiny's child
but right now that the business song is
really getting like really amping me up
so i put that on repeat
i very purposely had it in my headset in
my headphones and for 10 minutes 15
minutes before i came on i was doing my
hair i was repeating it and i was
singing out loud evan
and what tom does he then sees the text
and he comes in so imagine i'm freaking
gearing up and i'm like cultivating this
emotion because i'm like yeah i want to
like come and crush it and i need to
light the fire under my ass and he comes
and he hugs me and i just turned to him
and i was like thank you so much but i
can't have you hug me right now and he
was like you just texted me saying you
needed a hug and i was like that was an
hour ago
and it was like yeah i totally
understand but i've switched now i've
literally purposely
gone from now i need at least at least
15 minutes to gear up and purposely lean
into the emotion i want and so i just
said hey look i can't have a hug right
now i love you so much baby thank you so
much and you know what as soon as i'm
done with evan i'm gonna come and get
this hug from you
but that all takes like you said evan
self-awareness and i want people to hear
right now is that i've been doing this
for at least five years
so it's gonna take time and i think
everyone should take one step at a time
and say what is the emotion i'm trying
to
cultivate
and give yourself a month and say oh i
just put on a big watch like lisa yeah
it didn't work for me i just put on that
song oh this song really worked i just
tried a wonder woman necklace and i just
felt silly okay great what's that for
you
but work on it cultivate it use it so
that next time as you start to make
incremental steps you know these things
that work for you
but i'm just gonna add evan it works in
reverse
there was one time i was in get down
mode like i was just
hustle hustle from the moment i woke up
and as i said earlier i've got massive
blood issues so it was so intense all
day all day all day i went to sit down
to eat dinner at like 6 00 p.m or
whatever and my stomach is just the
knots you know it right when you're like
you've got the stress and the anxiety
and it's just hitting the fan and you're
just overwhelmed and i literally was
like this isn't gonna if i eat right now
my stomach will be in disarray for two
days and that will knock me out for two
days so right now
in real time what am i gonna do to make
sure because i've already been there i'm
very self-aware i know that eating when
my stomach is that tiny not it will
literally derail my health for two days
which means i can't eat which means that
i don't get brain clarity which means i
can't show up for evan carmichael on his
show so i make sure that i know okay
right now i can't eat self-awareness
number one
what do i do to make sure to cultivate
softness in me
because i'm really
too hard
and so i've learned over time it's
almost the opposite to everything i just
said evan
so what i do because i was like i need a
hug for my husband i know that works but
sometimes you don't want the hug because
you're just too tight so i literally
have a game plan step one go upstairs
tie your hair back because in case
people can't see it got braids i've got
like i really stylize my hair just tying
it up into a closet
you can have some heaven you can have
some
um
so i just tie it up into a bow makes me
feel relaxed i immediately took off my
makeup i immediately took off my jewelry
and i put on my fluffy pajama bottoms
that happened to be wonder woman that
isn't by accident either
i took my bar off like i really got
comfy
and i was like ah i took a deep breath
i washed my face
and now i had softened myself i took
time and i went to tom and i was like
babe can i have a hug he gave me a hug
that was the final little thing that i
needed and then i went and made dinner
and i was fine
i love it well we could go all day it's
amazing how many how many nuggets are in
here and what a wealth of knowledge and
inspiration this woman is uh some
highlights that we didn't touch on that
i love from the book um are
how to kill the squirrel so if you if
you're constantly being distracted how
do you kill the squirrel how do you stop
saying i'm sorry all the time as a
canadian that's maybe in our dna
we're always sorry for everything and
maybe my favorite is uh to sabotage the
self-sabotage which which was really
cool spin on it and i loved it um lisa
final question for people who
obviously go pick up the book guys we're
gonna link it up in the description
below be the first thing there go go
click it go by go support this amazing
human
for people who uh
might have you in their thoughts they're
watching this video they love you and
and if they've known you for a while
they wanna you know you've been in their
ecosystem for a while you've inspired
them if if you're in their thoughts or
you're in their prayers tonight
what would you have them pray for or
think of for you
cool the funny thing is it that's a very
um it's actually an uncomfortable
question and i'm saying that because
you're like i can always be so honest um
because it's uncomfortable for me to ask
people to think of me maybe i have to
work on it i'm actually haven't decided
yet if that's a good thing or a bad
thing even
you've actually caught me in real time
thinking out loud um
i know i'm not answering your question
but it's actually a little uncomfortable
here's what i think i would
want people to pray for and this is like
me trying to shift it about not being
about me
um that the book actually makes change
in people's lives
the the book actually makes change
because that's my ultimate goal so it's
like we all started this actually coming
full circle you're saying about new york
times number one like i desperately want
to be times number one that would be so
fun like something i never dreamed of it
would be so freaking fun
but you know what my north star really
is actually having someone read the book
and them actually making a change in
their lives
that that's like mind-blowing to me so
that's the really thing that i would
wish for
i love it the woman is lisa billy the
book is radical confidence go pick it up
check it out link in description below
lisa as always appreciate you love you
thank you for coming on
oh my god evan i just want to say i
freaking adore you you're so amazing
we're such good friends behind us with
the scenes we've been on vacation
together i mean you're so
amazing and when i reached out to you
say hey could i come on your show you
were so gracious to thank you as always
you're such an ama massive
support system to the bills we talk
about you all the time by the way all
the time i was in fact i was on discord
yesterday and i don't even think you
were there i kind of totally mentioned
you and i gave a whole story about me
and you and how wonderful you are so
like i'm sure everyone already knows all
your audience and they love you as well
but i just have to say like we so
appreciate everything you always do for
us you're an amazing human
thank you lisa appreciate you
if you want to see my recent one-on-one
with mel robbins check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i hate you evan i hope you lose
evan i hope your business goes bankrupt
evan evan you're a terrible person i
spent the first
40-some years of my life trying to be
somebody else